le fonds de solidarité ftq a reçu pour 3
milliard de demandes de rachat d'actions
au cours du dernier exercice c'est six
fois plus qu'à la même période lors de
l'exercice précédent
l'actif net du fonds chute de 12% en
raison de ses rachats à 13 milliards 800
millions de dollars l'action du fonds
est passé à 44 dollars 24 en baisse par
rapport au niveau de novembre dernier
mais en hausse sur 12 mois le rendement
de la dernière année du fonds est
positif 0,2 pour cent les six derniers
mois toutefois le dernier semestre
négatif -4 2% avec nos guettant morin
pdg du fonds de solidarité ftq bonsoir
monsieur morin on sent que ce lien alors
mars avril mai au coeur de la pandémie
61000 demande n'est ce pas de rachat la
moyenne sur 12 mois généralement ses 49
mille demandes
est ce que les gens ont pris peur compte
tenu de la chute boursière qu'on a connu
en février et en mars
évidemment des circonstances comme
puisqu'on un véhicule d'endémie
trimestre mais beaucoup de certitudes
mis beaucoup de cette subite chez les
gens en général avec le ce qui s'est
passé sur les marchés financiers nous on
a vraiment travaillé sur deux fronts
pendant la panacée dmitri mais cela on
dort triste le premier front qui était
d'investir dans les entreprises du
québec pour les soutenez donc on
investit 1.4 milliard 4 5 millions de
plus que ce qu'on avait prévu quelques
mois il ya plus oui en fait on avait un
plan en trois niveaux pour injecter du
capital dans les entreprises donc la
date à 4,5 millions ont été dédiés à ce
que nos entreprises et on a travaillé
aussi sur le son comme vous disiez signé
parce que nos actionnaires
on s'attendait à ça on est un peu à
l'image de la démographie du québec
d'une part et d'autre part on a donné
des rendements très attrayant cours des
10 dernières années dont certaines aux
actionnaires ont décidé de dates en meme
si c'etait la retraite de deux
millénaires et d'attendre
on en profite pour se faire racheter des
actifs 3 milliards
à de rachat sur 15 milliards d'actifs ça
donne un coup au fonds ftq ça écoutez il
faut relativiser tout ce rythme il ya ça
fait dans la vie j'imagine de plusieurs
fonds à l'échelle mondiale
d'autre part je voudrais 13 points 8
milliards de dettes on n'a aucune
obligation d'entre eux maintenant de
marge de crédit donc ce capital de il
est prêt à être déployé 14 milliards 2 3
1 et on faisait de travail de trois ans
donc on donne la solidité pour la faire
déficit syfy filmé deuxième vague et
puis rechute des marchés boursiers et
replonger des marchés est ce qu'à un
certain moment pour le fond ça peut
devenir problématique en termes de
liquidités de capacités d'intervention
non parce qu'il faut voir que le capital
que nous confient nos actionnaires du
capital pour la retraite donc ce qu'on
ait fait beaucoup au cours du dernier
trimestre pardon c'est qu'on ne
rachetait une portion de ces gens notent
d'ailleurs il faut pour me dis que le
font depuis son existence a racheté pour
un montant tout près de 13 milliards de
dollars à ses actionnaires cette partie
au fil du temps donc on savait que ça
arrive un jour
la rapidité nous a surpris évidemment
est ce qu'on a fait depuis les dernières
années c'est qu'on s'est assuré de
stimuler retraite chez les plus jeunes
donc par exemple cette année on a 46
nouveaux 46 mille pardons nouveaux
épargnants qui se sont joints au fond et
61% ces gens avaient un an de 40 ans
on s'assure au fil des add de renouveler
l'actionnariat 10 sont des gens qui sont
avec nous pendant longtemps aussi
pourquoi je suis continue effectivement
sa note si je vous écoute et j'ai pas
l'impression que malgré le trimestre
extrêmement pénible qu'on vient de
connaître que vous allez changer votre
stratégie pour autant n'est ce pas
absolument ok nous avons été nous avons
été créés pendant une crise
183 on en a vécu 2001 2009 celle d'un
peu spécial et ce domaine par des musées
pas comme une récession mais nous avons
la capacité de continuer à faire notre
mission évidemment jusqu'à quel point la
crise vous a touchée par ce qu'on a vu
puis on a parlé un peu plus tôt dans
l'émission on a vu une forte chute des
marchés et une forte remontée des
marchés ce qui donne finalement ce qui
vous donne finalement un rendement sur
12 mois qui est positif et un rendement
négatif sur les six derniers mois d'un
peu plus de 4%
jusqu'à quel point la variations
boursières touche une info comme le
vôtre qui investit aussi beaucoup dans
des entreprises privées dans l'économie
en général
sinon en fait le notre métier de base
c'est d'investir dans des entreprises
privées ce qu'on appelle le placement
privé mais aussi en la personne de nos
actifs qu'on dédie au grand marché donc
une portion en fait on a le devoir
d'investir selon la loi qui vise à
construire
on se doit d'investir 60 5% donc au
québec et 35% à 42 quai des bateaux dans
son ode enfants une portion de ses
actifs là est investi dans le marché
dans les marchés obligataires les
actions de grandes entreprises donc par
exemple elle est née la passion
on essaie de dire si le plus possible
nos actifs en fonction des situations
comme celles qu'on peut vivre en
terminant célia vous parliez d'un
milliard 400 millions d'investissements
au cours du dernier exercice est ce que
vous allez investir plus dans le
prochain exercice différé des savoirs
dépendent évidemment de l'évolution de
l'institution de macarons de faire
parler d'un mystère de 5,1 et sur les
cinq dernières années
en moyenne on investit de 800 millions à
un milliard on s'attendait sans chichis
des projets parfait monsieur morin merci
beaucoup
cb elle se finit en avant